- Let me tell you something.
We had four containers filled,
four 18-wheeler trucks
filled with Evian water
but I had left the week
before for two days
to go to meetings in Bermuda
for the America's Cup
and when I came back I
had missed the big meeting
with Customs and of
course Customs had said
to Billy and the gang you need to pay us
$175,000 in cash today for
us to release the water.
I went down, well Billy called me.
I'm gonna speak completely you know,
this won't go that far I'm sure
but Billy called and said,
"Andy we need you to take
one big thing for the team."
And I said, oh my gosh,
I've been taking something
for the team every day.
He said, "Well, you're
our wonderful gay leader
"and we need you to go down.
"Will you suck dick to
fix this water problem?"
And I said, Billy, what?
He said, "Andy, if you will go down
"and suck Cunningham's dick,"
who's the head of Customs
and get him to clear
all of the containers with water
you will save this festival
and I literally drove home, took a shower.
I drank some mouthwash, I'm
like oh my gosh I'm really,
and I got into my car to
drive across the island
to take one for the team.
And I got to his office, fully
prepared to suck his dick.
But he couldn't have been nicer
and he's like Andy listen,
I will release all the water,
I will let you serve it
but I wanna be one of the
first people to be paid
this import fee for what you're doing
and I said okay great and I got back
and I had all the water that we needed.
Can you imagine, in my
30 years of a career,
that this is what I was going to do?
I was going to do that
honestly to save the festival.